PROFESSOR: Great.
So I will begin
with phase shifts
and do the introduction of how
to make sure we can really--
so this is the
important part of this.
Just like when we added the
reflected and transmitted wave
we could find the
solution I'm going
to try to explain
why with this things
we can find
solutions in general.
So this is the subject
of partial waves,
and it's a nice subject,
a little technical.
There might seem to be
a lot of formulas here,
but the ideas are relatively
simple once one keeps in mind
the one dimensional analogies.
The one dimensional analogies
are very valuable here,
and we will
emphasize them a lot.
So we will discuss partial
waves and face shifts.
So it's time to simplify
this matters a little bit.
And to do that I
will assume from now
on that the potential is central
so v of r is equal to v of r.
That will simplify the
azimuthal dependence.
There will be no
azimuthal dependencies.
You see, the thing is
spherical is symmetric,
but still you're coming from
a particular direction, the z.
So you can expect now that
the scatter wave depends
on the angle of the
particle with respect
to z because it's
spherically symmetrical.
But it shouldn't depend
on five, the angle five,
should just depend on theta.
So expect f of theta.
Now, a free particle
is something
we all know how to
solve, e to the ikx.
Why do we bother with the
free particle in so many ways?
Because free particle
is very important.
Part of the solution
is free particles.
To some degree far away it
is free particles as well.
And we need to
understand free particles
in spherical coordinates.
So it's something we've done
in 805 and sometimes in 804,
and we look at the
radial equation which
is associated to
spherical coordinates
for a free particle.
So we'll consider free
particle and we'd say, well,
that's very simple
but it's not all that
simple in spherical
coordinates, and you'd say, OK,
if it's not simple, it's
spherical coordinates,
why do we bother?
We bother because
scattering is happening
in spherical coordinates.
So we can't escape having
to do the free particle
in spherical coordinates.
It is something you have to do.
So what are solutions in
spherical coordinates?
We'll have solution SI of r.
Remember the language
with coordinates
was a U of r divided by
r and of Ylm of omega.
That was a typical solution, a
single solution of the showing
our equation will--
the U only depends on l, the
m disappears, so this is r.
This r's are r's without the
vector because you're already
talking about the
radial equations,
and depend on the
energy and depend
on the value of the
l quantum number.
So what is the
Schrodinger equation?
The radial equation is
minus h squared over 2m,
the second the r squared plus.
h squared over 2m l times
l plus 1 over r squared.
Remember the potential
centrifugal barrier
in the effective potential,
then you would have v of r here,
but it's free particle,
so v of r is equal to 0.
So if nothing else,
U of El of little r
is equal to the
energy, which is h
squared k squared over 2m UEl.
And that's a
parliamentary session
of the energy in terms of
the k squared, like that.
Well, there's lots of
h squared, k squared,
and 2m's, so we can
get rid of them.
Cancel the h squared over 2m.
You get minus d second
dr squared plus l times l
plus 1 over r.
UEl is equal to k squared UEl.
It's a nice equation.
It's the equation
of the free particle
in spherical coordinates.
Now, this is like the
Schrodinger equation.
And I think when you look at
that you could get puzzled
whether or not the value
of k squared or the energy
might end up being quantized.
With the Schrodinger
equation many times
quantized is the energy, but
here it shouldn't happen.
This is a free particle.
All values of k
should be allowed,
so there should be
no quantization.
This is an r squared here.
You can see one reason,
at least analytically,
that there is no quantization
is that you can define
a new variable row
equal kr and then
this whole differential
equation becomes
minus the second the row
squared plus l times l
plus 1 over row squared.
Well, I can put the other
number in there as well,
or should I not?
No, it's not done here.
UEl is equal to UEl, and the k
squared disappeared completely.
That tells you that the case
will kind of get quantized.
If there is a solution of
this differential equation
it holds for all values of k.
And these are going to
be like plane waves,
and maybe that's
another reason you
can think that k
doesn't get quantized
because these solutions are
not normalizable anyway,
so it shouldn't get quantized.
So with this equation in here
we get the two main solutions.
The solutions of this
differential equation
are vessel functions,
spherical vessel functions.
UEl is equal to a constant
Al times row times the vessel
function lowercase j of row.
There's a row times
that function.
That's the way it shows up.
It's kind of interesting.
It's because in fact you
have to divide U by r,
so that would mean
dividing U by row,
and it means that the radial
function is just the vessel
function without anything else.
And then there's the
other vessel function,
the n of l a row times
of n of l of row.
So those are spherical
vessel functions.
As you're familiar
from the notation
that j is the one that
this healthy at row
equals 0 doesn't diverge
the n is the solution
that diverges at the origin.
And both of them
behave nicely far away.
So Jl of x goes like 1 over x
sine of x minus l pi over 2,
and ADA l of x
behaves like minus 1
over x cosine of x
minus l pi over 2.
This is for x big, x
much greater than 1,
you have this behavior.
So these are our
solutions, and here is
the thing that we have to do.
We have to rewrite our solutions
in terms of spherical waves
because this was the spherical
wave so we should even write
this part as a spherical wave.
And this is a very
interesting and in some way
strange representation of E to
the ikz You have E to the ikz
that you have an
intuition for it
as a plane wave
in the z direction
represent it as an infinite
sum of incoming and outgoing
spherical waves.
That's what's going to happen.
So this is the last
thing we need do here.
We have that e to the ikz
is a plane wave solution,
so it's a solution
of a free particle,
so I should be able to write the
superpositions of the solutions
that we have found.
So it should be a superposition
of solutions of this type.
So it could be a sum of
coefficients al times,
well, alm you think of
some a's times solutions.
Remember, we're writing
a full solution,
so a full solution
you divide by r.
So you divide by this quantity.
So you could have
an alm Jl of row
plus Blm ATA l of row times Ylm.
So this should be
a general solution,
and that would be a sum
over l's and m's of all
those quantities.
But that's a lot more
than what you need.
First, this does not
diverge near r equals 0.
It has no divergence anywhere
and the ATAs or the n's, I
think they're n such and not
ATAs, the n's diverge for row
equal to 0.
So none of this are necessary,
so I can erase those.
l and m.
But there is more.
This function is
invariant and there
are some beautiful rotations.
If you have your axis
here, here's the z,
and you have a point here and
you rotate that the value of z
doesn't change.
It's independent of
phi for a given theta,
z just depends on
r of cosine theta.
So there's no phi dependence
but all the Ylm's with m
difference from 0
have phi dependent.
So m cannot be here either.
m must be 0.
So you must be
down to sum over l,
al some coefficient,
Jl of row, Yl0.
And all of those would be
perfectly good plane wave
solutions.
Whatever numbers you
choose for the little al's,
those are good solutions
because we've build them
by taking linear combinations
of exact solutions
of this equation.
But to represent this
quantity the al's
must take particular values.
So what is that formula?
That formula is quite
famous, and perhaps even you
could discuss this
in recitation.
e to the ikz, which is e
to the ikr cosine theta,
is the sum 4 pi.
Now you have to get all
the constants right.
Square root of 4 pi,
sum from l equals 0
to infinity, square
root of 2l plus 1.
Coefficients are pretty funny.
They get worse very fast.
Now you have of i to the
I, i to the l, Yl0 of theta
doesn't depend on phi, Jl of kr.
This is the expansion
that we need.
There's no way we can make
problems with this problem
unless we have this expansion.
But now if Y the intuition
that I was telling you
of these waves
coming in and out,
well, you have e to the
ikz, you sum an infinite sum
over partial waves.
A partial wave is a
different value of l.
These are partial waves.
As I was saying, any solution
is a sum of partial waves
is a sum over l.
And where are the waves?
Well, the Jl of kr far away
is a sine, and the sine of x
is an exponential ix minus
e to the minus ix over 2.
So here you have
exponentials of e to the ikr
and exponentials of
e to the minus ikr,
which are waves that are
here like outgoing waves
and incoming waves.
So the E to the ikz's are sum of
ingoing and outgoing spherical
waves.
And that's an intuition that
we will exploit very clearly
to solve this problem.
So we will do that next.